er ist eine person ist der ist doch mal
ein fingerabdruck uns einfach was dabei
gedacht haben als staat polizei hallo
mein name ist khan herzlich willkommen
wir heute meine lieben freunde zu einem
neuen video und ihr seht schon ich bin
mal draußen unterwegs und zwar stehe ich
hier vom bundespolizei aus und
fortbildungszentrum eschwege und ich bin
nicht allein sondern wir schauen den
leuten von der bundespolizei heute meist
ein bisschen über die schulter schauen
das hier so abgeht
das ganze für euch zu info hier ist auch
ein interaktives video ja das heißt ihr
könnt selbst bestimmen wie es weiter
gehen was wir machen sollen und wir
dürfen heute den fall lösen
[Musik]
hallo hallo luca in ruhrort herzlich
willkommen wir uns in eschwege
dankeschön
was haben wir für euch vorbereitet wir
wollen euch im polizeialltag mal zeigen
man von unseren anwärtern
dafür haben wir verschiedene kleine
aufgaben lösen im kleinen fall gibt es
eine kleine challenge aber was ich noch
nicht wisst teilweise gegeneinander
mal gucken wir mal seine kollegen mal
aber auch im wettbewerb zwischen und was
ja auch noch nicht wisst der gewinner
darf sich für den anderen eine strafe
ausdenken
unsere auszubildenden sind gerade in
einer polizeilichen situation und da
wären wir mal gucken ob wir denen helfen
können die können euch gebrauchen dann
jetzt wisst ihr eigentlich was die
hauptaufgaben der bundespolizei sind
flughäfen richtig rennen genau wir haben
die flughäfen in deutschland wir haben
alle großen bahnhöfe dann der
grenzschutz küstenwache
[Musik]
kann ich das ding da haben unsere
anwerber ein verdächtiges fahrzeug
rausgezogen
[Musik]
also folgendes wir haben eben dieses
wort sich angehalten und dort haben wir
gestohlene kennzeichen gefunden
deswegen werden wir jetzt einmal das
ganze auto durchsuchen kommt an besser
erstmal mit jetzt redet einzeln an also
es einen challenge für euch gegen
gegeneinander ja und dann auch zeit ja
von euch beiden der als erster etwas
findet beziehungsweise schneller hat das
ganze gewonnen
das wichtigste ist dass hier
systematisch vorgeht ihr sucht euch eine
ecke raus
der anfang wollt schaut in jedem
hohlraum rhein ihr habt alles hoch was
beweglich ist möchte man anfangen oder
soll ich als erstes oder ganz einfach
das ganze ist getrennt das heißt du dir
jetzt weg ja kein glück wünsche ich dir
auf die plätze fertig los
ich wollte einen super denn ich wollte
nicht jetzt erst eingehen sondern ich
würde als erstes vorne gucken weil jeder
denkt du hast das im kofferraum
denn hier das ist das ist eine warnweste
glaube ich das nie waren bisher boden
gefunden
unter den sitzen auch maschinen in der
natur auch schon nachgeschaut natürlich
nicht hat dank ich dachte ich zunächst
gefunden hier
jetzt auch nicht ich will ein paar
zweifel sogar ob er ist ganz wichtig
dass du in jedem raum wirklich rein
chance und unter jede plastikabdeckung
lieder so auf machen kannst was du da
auch mal reinschauen öffnet verdienen
jährlich nur zwischen kunden vielleicht
auch mal reingucken wenn du was genau
auf machen kannst
aha
aha reisepässe nicht so schlecht die
dinger noch 3 ich habe lange gebraucht
oder 15
wie kommt man auf die idee dass hier in
die batterie zu packen ja man wird
kreativ und ich gucke da noch in dieses
ding rein freuen
ich war nicht so schnell aber ich glaube
julia wird auch nicht schneller sein
ich sage nicht wow gar nicht okay aber
nicht nur auf jeden fall machbar das
zuschlagen selbstwert hier
ich schaue noch ein bisschen zu und sagt
vielleicht ein zwei sätze auf die plätze
fertig los dass hier verdächtig könnte
dass irgendein also ich hatte eine
stelle wird auch mal so ein bisschen
outside the box denken also ich bin halt
räder immer sehr cool ja unten drunter
zu schauen das auch nicht verkehrt
das ist auf jeden fall nichts verboten
ist kann man das die augen aufmachen
nein das ist es nicht
auch hierbei in jeden raum gucken und
ganz wichtig auch unter jede
plastikabdeckung dem spaß hier dran ich
habe ja wenig wahrscheinlich komplett
falsch bin oder aber weil alles auftrag
muss man aufbauen kann
wo man auch was mich denken kann daran
kann man ziehen aber daraus den zu
verstecken ist schwierig kannst du ja
sollte helfen
das sind bestimmt falsche pässe wie wir
den behinderten anfang seiten falsch ist
es nicht wir wissen ja auch vorher nicht
wo es versteckt ist aber ich glaube wir
waren relativ gleich von derzeit also so
wie es sich angefühlt hat in hand
unterschied eine minute ein schwein
schlechter scheint ja mein gott ich
dachte gerade schneller
das hat sich für mich mega stelle
angefühlt bestrafung später die jetzt
gerade bei julia ausreise ist auch
einmal ein typ
das hat mir richtig gut gemacht hat sich
ein glückwunsch dazu danke aber
polizeiarbeit endet nicht hier in der
stelle wir machen weiter entweder gehen
wir jetzt von den tatverdächtigen in
vernehmung raum und gucken mal was so zu
sagen hat oder nehmen wir uns die
kennzeichen und presse vor
und wir haben mal gucken ob er darauf
fingerabdrücke von ihm oder vielleicht
anderen verdächtigen finden wo wollen
wir weitermachen
[Musik]